[APPLAUSE]
GREG ESTREN: Welcome
to 111 Eighth Avenue.
I know most of you are already
quite familiar with this place.
It's Google's New York
City headquarters,
and somewhere you probably
spend an awful large amount
of your time every day.
It's a gigantic,
bustling building,
filling an entire
block of Lower Chelsea,
and sporting sweeping views
of the midtown skyline
to the north, the
financial district,
and upper New York
Bay to the south,
and vast expanses of the
Hudson River just to the west.
It has one of the
largest footprints
of any building in Manhattan.
It's 16 stories high.
It was the second-largest
building on Earth
when it was originally built.
120,000 yards of concrete.
31,000 tons of steel.
12 million bricks.
Four acres of glass.
It's still one of the largest
buildings in New York City,
a skyscraper laid
on its side, bigger
than the Empire State Building.
This is clearly a curious
and unique building.
There's nothing else quite
like it here in the city.
And it's obviously a
successful, vibrant home
to at least one major internet
tech company of the modern era.
[LAUGHTER]
But why does it say "Port of New
York Authority" on both sides?
What does "inland
terminal number one" mean?
Why are there bumpers
lining the walls
down 15th and 16th Street?
[LAUGHTER]
It's a serious question.
Why is the 15th floor elevator
lobby so different and nice?
[LAUGHTER]
Why are none of the
neighboring buildings
anything like this one?
Just what is this place, anyway?
Why was it built on
this block in Chelsea?
Why is it so big?
Why is it even here?
The story of this building
is first and foremost
the story of this-- 1,500 square
miles of raw earth and water,
nestled away in a little
corner of the Atlantic Ocean.
771 miles of waterfront.
Over eight bays, four rivers,
four straits, 17 counties,
200 municipalities, and
one major world city.
It would take a 10-knot
boat about eight days
to navigate the entire thing,
assuming they're not navigating
in the middle of the night.
This is the port of New York.
It's an enormously
rich resource.
Four times the size
of Boston's port,
six times the size of
Baltimore's, 20 times the size
of Philadelphia's, and it's
the foundation on which New
York was built. It's the
reason this city was created,
why it grew in the
way that it did,
and why it's the big
metropolis it is today.
Before the Industrial
Revolution,
New York was a very different
city than it is today.
In particular, transportation
was absolutely abysmal.
If you wanted to get
somewhere by land,
basically, you would have
to take a stagecoach,
maybe take a horse, or most
likely, walk over dirt,
rocky, gravel-ish roads
through the woods.
We didn't have roads
like we have today.
It wasn't particularly
pleasant or fast.
Getting from New
York to Boston might
take about six days' time.
So in this period,
everything moved by water.
Boats were a really big deal.
Oceans, bays, and rivers--
that's how things moved around.
And the bays in New
York in particular
were attractive to settling
the city in the first place.
But come the 19th century,
all of this started to change.
As a part of the
Industrial Revolution,
there was a sort of
sub-piece of that,
known as the
Transportation Revolution.
And it massively
changed the country,
leading it into the
modern country and economy
that we know today.
In particular, at the
beginning of the 19th century,
there were two
critical innovations
that had big impacts.
One of them was the
steamship pictured here.
Someone finally figured out
how to take a steam engine
and put it on a
boat, which meant now
boats could travel upstream just
as easily as they could travel
downstream.
It sounds kind of simple, but
that absolutely revolutionized
transportation and the economy
in the country, and the world.
This was used in
conjunction with canals,
which were used to create
waterways into the interior,
so it was possible to start
settling and creating economies
outside of the ocean
and waterfronts.
In particular,
there was one canal
that had massive, massive
impact on the country,
and that was the Erie Canal.
It was started
in, I think, 1824,
and it connected New
York City with Buffalo.
As soon as it opened, the time
for traveling between Buffalo
and New York cut by
about half, and the cost
of moving goods and
freight plummeted by 95%.
It basically put the
Midwest on the map,
and massively expanded
the size of the country,
and created an economy
which linked the Midwest,
and linked the Northeast, and
then with Europe on beyond.
And New York City was at
the center of all of this.
This was the era that New York
really came into preeminence.
vaulted beyond Philadelphia
to become the country's
preeminent city.
But it's these guys that had
the biggest impact of them all.
It's these guys who
were more responsible
than probably any kind of
technological innovation,
or definitely form
of transportation,
to create the modern
country that we know.
Someone finally figured out
how to make land travel viable,
and that absolutely plummeted
the amount of time and cost
that it took to move all
throughout the country.
This is most famously evidenced
by the Transcontinental
Railroad, which literally
stitched together the country
from coast to coast.
It ended up producing
an economy that
was on a larger scale
than anything that
had been seen before
in this country,
and a country that's
literally larger
than it had ever been before.
And New York continued
to be the center of this.
Those trading routes
established by the Erie Canal
continued to be used
by the railroads,
and by the end of
the 19th century,
New York ended up bigger,
more important, busier,
than it had ever been before.
This was the era of
the mighty railroads,
of the New York Central
and the Pennsylvania.
It was the era of the
Vanderbilts, Grand Central
Station, and the
original Penn Station.
Big stuff happening then.
But by the time the 20th
century came around,
this was starting
to create problems.
New York was bigger than ever.
76 million tons of
freight was moving by rail
through the city, over three
million railroad cars per year.
There was more
manufacturing in New York
than Philadelphia,
Chicago, Cleveland, and St.
Louis combined.
About half of the
country's foreign commerce
moved just through
this single port.
It was by far the largest port
in the country, an operating
level of unprecedented scale.
Now, this sounds all
fantastic and wonderful.
This doesn't sound
like a problem.
But the problem
was, it was finally
hitting a point-- this
port is big, it's rich,
it's an enormous resource,
but it's not infinitely big.
And it's finally starting to
hit its limit of scalability.
It never developed in
any kind of coherent way.
It was always
basically a land grab
when the steamships, and
eventually the railroads,
built into here.
It was just private companies
competing with each other,
angling with each other to try
to make a buck over another.
Which means that there was no
consolidated use of this port,
and at this level of
scale and economy,
it was really starting to
reach the limits of what
could be handled.
New York, in particular,
had three disadvantages
that were a real problem
for it by this point.
First, it's a city of islands.
You could be an
orange manufacturer,
orange grower-- probably
not from an orange factory--
in California.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
Who knows how it went back then.
You can load your oranges
up onto a railroad car,
transport them through
the Rocky Mountains,
through the plains of
the Midwest, thousands
and thousands of miles, all the
way through the entire country,
only to get stuck on
the New Jersey Shore.
One small but big enough river
away from the actual city.
This is a real problem.
What do you do about this?
At this level of
scale, how do you
move all of this
stuff this last mile?
And at this point, there were no
tunnels or bridges or anything
that could accommodate this.
And there kind of
still aren't today.
Not for freight, at least.
So what did the
railroads do about this?
Well, they put their
railroad cars onto boats.
They ended up having a massive
amount of transfer stations
and terminals on
the New Jersey side,
where they would take these
specially-made barges that
had rail cars on them, put the
railroad cars onto the barges,
float them across
the Hudson River,
and then transfer
them to receiving
points on Manhattan, where they
could finally be dealt with,
received over in the city.
These were called car floats,
and they were a critical link
in which freight moved into and
out of the city in this time.
The other problem that
New York had was this
is a very fragmented network.
These mighty
railroads of the time,
they were independent
companies, and they
were competing with each other.
There were about 12 of them.
It looks a little bit
different in this diagram.
It says 11, but
the numbers varied.
There were 12 of them serving
the city, of which about nine
of them ended up on
the side of New Jersey.
And there were a few other
tracks in a few other places.
But these were
different companies
competing with each
other, and they did not
share infrastructure.
So what that meant was that
all this infrastructure--
railroads, stations, piers,
ferries, tugboats, lighters,
car floats, motor trucks,
warehouses, and markets-- was
duplicated 12 times.
This was not efficient.
And then, the third
problem that New York had
was a simple political one.
This is one big,
natural, unified port,
but it's politically
split in two.
On this side, you had
the State of New Jersey.
And on this side, the
State of New York.
And they didn't always
agree with each other,
so it wasn't always easy to
work on these situations,
get the political will to.
So the practical
consequences of this,
was that it was enormously
expensive to ship stuff
to and from New York.
It was enormously expensive
to bridge that last mile.
It was stated that
it cost just as much
to take freight from
Buffalo to New York
as it did to cross the
Hudson River itself.
And even worse, because
these railroads,
they all had their own
proprietary networks--
a rail belonged to
one company and didn't
belong to another company--
you got some absurd
routing scenarios.
So here's an example where
somebody was shipping freight.
I don't remember
the kind of freight.
But they were shipping
from basically Jersey
City to Jersey City.
And you can see where the
origin and the destination is.
There's about, I think,
a four mile difference.
But because of the way the
tracks were owned and laid out,
it actually shipped
over 58 miles, over,
I think, four days to
get to its destination.
The railroads who
shipped, they wanted
to maximize the amount of time
this stuff was on their rails,
because they made
more money doing that.
Sometimes they just
got stupidly absurd.
This is 180 miles.
And then another
consequence of all this,
which is all this
duplicated infrastructure
created a lot of wasted space.
50% of New Jersey's
waterfront was
used by railroad yards,
and 43 piers on Manhattan.
This was considered an
enormous waste of space.
It was much preferred to
use piers for shipping,
and passenger liners,
and that sort of thing,
as opposed to unnecessary
railroad infrastructure.
And of course,
Manhattan's west side,
with all this infrastructure
on the Manhattan side,
was congested beyond belief.
Every railroad had their own
receiving stations and delivery
stations.
And merchant trucks
from the city
would have to come to them,
and fill up the streets,
and load cars on the streets.
And there was congestion
and waste everywhere.
And the whole west side-- we're
in this west side, kind of--
was basically a disaster.
And it wasn't just
economic concerns
about New York that
were the problems here.
There were actually
national security concerns
for the security of
the entire country.
This really came to a head
in World War I. World War
I ended up giving
the port more usage
than it ever had in
history, as the United
States was trying to apply
the war effort over in Europe.
And what happened is the
port couldn't handle it.
There were railroad cars backed
up all the way to Buffalo.
They ultimately had to divert
traffic to other ports,
like Philadelphia and
Boston, because they
couldn't handle
all the load that
was going through the port.
In 1917, the government
even temporarily
nationalized the railroad
network in New York,
in order to make this
stuff work efficiently.
This was basically a crisis.
This was a system that
was not scaling, and was
starting to fall apart
in a time of real need.
And that was a real concern.
Things were not well in
the port of New York.
And then finally, all these
things coming together,
this created this concern
that New York, preeminent
as it was, this
wasn't guaranteed it
was going to last.
It might slip.
And this wasn't just theory.
This wasn't just paranoia.
This was actually happening.
Since 1890, New York's share
of the commerce of the country
was starting to slip.
And other ports were
very aware of this,
and they were fighting
very aggressively in order
to get their share that
New York couldn't handle.
There was very serious
concern about this,
the future of New
York if they couldn't
get their act together.
World War I, that
experience with World War I,
was a huge wake-up call for the
area that things were not well.
But it took an even
more immediate crisis
to actually trigger
the will for change.
This happened about 1915, and it
was called the New York Harbor
Crisis.
Basically, New
Jersey was looking
at this situation
like, OK, yeah,
it's really expensive
to do all this stuff,
and have these car floats, and
all these duplicated stations,
and all this extra effort it
takes to get to Manhattan.
But why is that New
Jersey's problem?
You can get to New
Jersey just fine.
You don't have to cross any
rivers to get to New Jersey.
Why should it cost as
much to ship to New Jersey
as it does to New York?
It's a fair question.
So New Jersey filed a
petition with the ICC.
Without getting in much detail,
the ICC was a federal agency.
They set the rates of how
much it cost to ship things.
If you're going to
ship cotton to Boston,
it will cost you
like five cents.
And they existed for a large
part of the 20th century.
They decided rates.
So New Jersey filed a
petition with the ICC,
asking for cheaper rates to
New Jersey than to New York.
What that meant in
practice was they
wanted to split up the port.
And that was really
scary to a lot of people.
It wasn't clear
what would happen
if you split up the port.
Maybe it would help New Jersey.
Maybe industry would
just leave outright,
and things would get much worse.
The ICC ultimately ruled
against New Jersey.
They decided that the
significance of this being
a unified port is
important and meaningful,
and it's not a really
good idea to split it up.
But they did issue a warning.
They said, yes, your point,
New Jersey, is valid.
Things are not well here.
If you guys don't get
your act together,
we may change our
mind later, and we
may make a different decision.
What this meant was
that the status quo
was no longer an option.
There were only two
choices at this point,
just after World War
I-- fix this port,
or break up this port.
That's what they
had to choose from.
So what the states did is
they appointed a commission.
It was a bi-state commission
run by both states.
It was called the New York,
New Jersey Port and Harbor
Development Commission.
And they were tasked in
1917 with, basically,
looking at the situation
and figuring out
what to do about it.
They did an exhaustive study
of the port over three years.
It was the most exhaustive
study of this port ever done.
And ultimately, it
provided a 495-page report,
which had a recommended
plan of what to do,
and the structure for
a regional authority
that would be empowered
to execute that plan.
This regional authority is
what became the Port Authority.
It was started
just a year later.
They were an amazingly
innovative and controversial
political structure,
in way more detail
than I can get into right now.
But the gist of it is they're
an organization that's
owned by both New
York and New Jersey.
Both states own it.
And they're empowered
to make improvements
from a holistic perspective over
the port region, that satellite
image that we saw before.
The plan that this
commission came up with
was called the
Comprehensive Plan,
and it was basically a
fundamental reorganization
of the region's transportation
railroad network,
focusing on unification,
de-duplicating all
this duplicated infrastructure,
rational planning, efficiency.
Again, looking at
the whole thing
from a holistic perspective
for the health of the region.
So with that, New
York and New Jersey,
with ratification by
Congress and the President
of United States, allowed the
creation of the Port Authority
as an organization
in April 1921.
They were seeded with
$100,000 of seed money,
and given eight
months to produce
a version of this plan
that could save New York.
Let's take a look at
the Comprehensive Plan.
It looks like a mess, I know.
But the point of it is
to clean up the mess.
The basic gist of it
is, let anything easily
get anywhere in the port.
Things like water, rivers,
bays, shouldn't be a barrier
towards things moving around.
So the core elements
of this were
to connect New Jersey
with Long Island,
with Brooklyn and
Queens and Long Island.
You see a light blue
line running through.
The idea was to
create a special rail
line which connects with all
the independent companies' rail
lines.
So stuff coming in from any
one private company's line
can connect to that line, run
through all of New Jersey,
run through a newly built tunnel
connecting Jersey City to Bay
Ridge or Brooklyn,
in the dark blue,
and then run up through
Brooklyn and Queens,
therefore connecting New
Jersey with Long Island.
As for Manhattan, the
problem with Manhattan
itself, it was a really
awesome proposal that they had.
It was really neat and crazy.
I'm going to go to the next
slide to zoom in a little bit,
because it's easier to
see in the next slide.
They proposed, instead
of all these car floats,
creating this loop of an
auto-electrified rail system.
Kind of like a
Disneyland People Mover.
Railroad freight would transfer
from the New Jersey side
rail yards onto these
automatically moving cars,
go through a new tunnel
underneath the Hudson River,
deep into Manhattan, where
they would be deposited
into a series of inland
stations strategically
placed throughout the
city, that would whisk them
up through elevators-- not
like elevators we have in here,
just to be clear--
but through elevators,
where they would do the
processing they needed to do.
In order to figure out how
many stations would be needed
and where they might
be in order to supply
the entirety of Manhattan,
they did some studies.
Over here is a study of the
freight density of Manhattan.
Basically, each
one of those dots
represents a certain
amount of freight being
processed through the city.
So they plotted this onto
the map of Manhattan,
and then created
nine-ish different zones
of equal freight density.
And then, from those
zones, they decided
they would have one
terminal serving
each one of those zones.
So the idea of it was
it would kind of be
like a post office for freight.
If you're a merchant
and you need
to deliver freight,
rather than going
to every single
different railroad
station's individual
depot station,
you would just go
to the terminal
that was serving your zone.
It would be inland, away
from the waterfront,
which they wanted to use for
boats and that sort of thing.
And then, the Port
Authority would figure out
how to get that
to the railroads,
through this
auto-electric system.
So this is basically the idea.
But they recognized
that some of this stuff
would not happen overnight.
You can't just build
tunnels overnight.
And there was an immediate
crisis to be solved.
So they also came up with
a plan for present relief,
a limited version this which
they could execute immediately,
to get immediate effect.
And the idea that was,
basically, take all these car
floats and consolidate them.
And instead, use these
little courier trucks
which would pick up
on the New Jersey side
from the rail stations,
and then either get ferried
across the river, or maybe use
the newly built Holland Tunnel
which was getting created.
And then drive all the way
into these inland stations,
without the rail
connection, without needing
to build the tunnels.
And then build the
stations to support them.
So that was the idea
for immediate execution.
And they took that idea, they
negotiated with the railroads,
and then they decided
they were going
to focus all their efforts,
all their initial efforts,
into one single project-- the
Union Inland Terminal Number
One.
So they got to work.
They hired the architectural
firm of Abbott, Merkt & Company
in order to prepare
the plans and start
building the buildings.
The initial place they were
going to build it was not here.
It was in Zone 3W,
which is between Spring
Street and Christopher Street,
just to the south of here.
The plan was to build a 206-foot
wide by 500-foot building.
The terminal would be the ground
floor and the basement only.
On top of that,
everything on top
would be 14 floors
of office space,
the point being that they could
rent out and then subsidize
the cost of the
terminal, because this
had to be self-supporting.
They couldn't take taxpayer
dollars to support this.
So this was the plan.
They presented it
to the railroads,
and the railroad said, no.
Not big enough.
It's not going to handle all
the freight in this zone.
It's not going to be able
to serve all the railroads.
But maybe even more
importantly, they
didn't think the
location was fair.
If you look at this map here,
any of the black piers, those
are railroad piers, piers that
were owned by the railroads.
The original spot in 3W that
they were trying to plan for
was probably
somewhere around here,
which meant that some
railroads already
had station facilities
around there,
and they didn't
think that was fair.
It might disrupt the
competitive balance
of the different railroads.
So they were really
wary about that.
So basically, they said, go
back to the drawing board,
give us something different.
The Port Authority did
that, and then they
suggested a new location.
OK, we'll try Zone
4W, right around here.
That looks a lot more fair.
No railroad infrastructure
anywhere around there.
It would be an even
bigger terminal, too,
260 feet by 800 feet.
Could hold 100 merchant
trucks at a time.
And it would have these
amazing truck elevators,
so the tenants in
the upper levels,
they could get
store-door delivery
right to their storefront, even
if their storefront happened
to be on the sixth floor
of the building, which
is really exciting.
The exterior would be,
quote-unquote, "Simple,
inexpensive, but
dignified and pleasing."
[LAUGHTER]
So they presented
this to the railroads,
and the railroads said, OK.
However, this is not mandatory.
We have our own stations.
This works for us.
This is an experiment.
We don't know how
this is going to go,
so we're not going to
be required to use this.
It'll be an opt-in
kind of thing,
and we'll just do this as an
experiment and see how it goes.
So the Port Authority said, OK.
And they signed a contract
with eight of the railroads
on August of 1930,
promising to have
this ready within 16 months.
And then, committing to
making two more of them
if requested-- if and when
requested by the railroads.
But you know, we'll see.
So the Port Authority
got to work.
First off, of course, they
had to clear off the old site.
This was the city.
There was stuff on the blocks.
It wasn't empty fields.
So they went to work,
and ultimately they
had to purchase and raise about
73 buildings on this block
between 15th and 16th Street,
Eighth and Ninth Avenue.
It included two garages,
a movie theater, a hotel,
a boy's club-- I don't even
know what that means, but--
[LAUGHTER]
And maybe the coolest,
the five-story GB Seeley
carbonated beverage plant.
It was a soda manufacturer right
in the middle of the block,
right around there.
And they were apparently pretty
well-known back in the day.
They had a brand that
was known, and they
were a significant
manufacturer of soda,
before they were ultimately
bought out by Canada Dry.
Here is a picture of the site.
That right there is the GB
Seeley factory, making soda,
probably halfway down
15th and 16th Streets.
This is the view on Eighth
Avenue between 15th and 16th.
And you can see the Village
Theater right about two-thirds
of the way up.
This is looking at
15th Street west.
You can see Chelsea
Market in the distance.
This is what Ninth
Avenue looked like.
Demolition began in 1931.
The superstructure started
to rise in October of 1931.
Pretty cool pictures.
On December of 1932,
the elevators--
these infamous truck
elevators-- they
had to move them in from
the Otis Elevator Company
in Hamilton, New Jersey.
They were so big
that they filled up
the entirety of
the Holland Tunnel,
and they had to
close the thing off
with a police escort from
4:00 to 5:00 in the morning
as they were coming in.
The building was finally
finished in September of 1932.
Total cost of $16 million.
In January of 1933, they had a
dedication for the elevators.
They invited 62 guests to
come drive up to the building,
drive into one of the elevators
up to the sixth floor,
where they would have a
banquet dinner inside one
of the other elevators.
[LAUGHTER]
It was apparently
a really nice time.
On February of 1933, they
had the formal dedication
for the building.
Dignitaries, speeches,
that kind of thing.
Howard Coleman, an executive
of the Port Authority,
he placed a metal box in the
cornerstone of the building,
wherever that is.
In that, he placed a copy
of the previous day's
"New York Times", copied the
contract with the railroads
for building this building,
and an image of when
FDR was on the site, first
breaking ground with a steam
shovel.
The first user of the terminal
was on October 3rd of 1932.
It was a truck with the American
Tobacco Company that came in,
8:00 AM for a shipment.
Everyone was excited.
So how did it go?
[LAUGHTER]
The building actually has a
really storied and interesting
history, in my opinion.
They called the building above
the terminal the Port Authority
Commerce Building.
And it had quite a variety
of tenants over the time.
These included Emerson
Radio for a while.
Macy's had some of their
toy storage division
on the third floor.
Woolworth had the entire
third floor for a while.
The Triborough Bridge Authority
had their executive offices
there.
That's where Robert Moses,
if anyone knows him,
sat for a while.
And various New Deal
agencies from the FDR era.
Wrigley Chewing Gum
had about a quarter
of the eleventh
floor for a while.
It's interesting to
think about these things
as we walk through
these floors ourselves,
chewing gum being
made over here.
But probably the coolest
tenant of them all, by far,
was Commerce Hall.
It was the largest exhibition
center in New York.
This was before the
Javits Center existed.
It took up the entire second
floor of the building.
They had a lot of trade shows,
like the National Business
Show, the National Metals
Exhibition, things like that.
But they also had some quirkier
stuff, the Leisure League
of America's Hobby Round-Up,
and the Empire Cat Club's
annual cat show.
The coinciding mouse and
rat show was canceled.
The cat show
organizers apologized,
but denied emphatically
that any of the cats
consumed the exhibits.
[LAUGHTER]
But by far the coolest
exposition of all of them
was the Ford
exposition of progress.
It opened up simultaneously with
the opening of Commerce Hall.
It was a massive World's
Fair-style celebration
of the auto industry,
run by Ford.
It included live steel
forging, happening on-premises,
a miniature rubber plantation
that people could check out,
a working assembly line, and
a replica of the brick house
where Ford built his
first car in 1893.
Over 19 days, it had
2.3 million visitors,
and was considered, apparently,
the largest exhibition
show ever in New York.
Ford himself, and his wife,
and his daughter all attended.
It was also the site for the
city's first rooftop heli-port.
The Port Authority was very
interested in helicopter
transit as a possible
way to move quickly
throughout the city.
You hear this theme about
efficiently moving things
throughout the city.
Helicopters were very
interesting in this regard
to the Port Authority.
It was built in 1950,
on Ninth Avenue rooftop.
You can still see
the structure of it
today, although
there's no helicopters.
They had about 10 takeoffs and
landings happening per day.
It was also the site of the
city's first rooftop helicopter
crash.
[LAUGHTER]
In July of 1955, a
helicopter apparently
was trying to take off, and was
stuck to a power cable which
they didn't unlatch.
It fell upside-down
onto the 16th floor,
dropped down to the
15th floor, and then
stayed stuck there,
while a burning gas
tank fell onto Ninth Avenue.
Both the pilot and the
photographer on the helicopter
were OK.
They both survived,
so it was OK.
No, that was good.
The building also
had its fair share
of interesting crime stories.
It was the first hit,
in 1952, of "Mad Bomber"
Georgia Metesky's terror rein
of New York City over 16 years,
in a phone booth in the lobby.
In 1944, it was the
scene of a payroll heist
with masked bandits,
submachine guns,
and pistol duels in the street.
But by far the most infamous
and devastating caper of them
all was the great
1936 poultry-napping
of a $500 turkey hen from the
poultry industry's exposition.
And I'm just going to read "The
New York Times" play-by-play
on this, because it's worth it.
[LAUGHTER]
"On Wednesday morning,
the drunken man
showed up at the exposition,
red of face, bleary of eye,
and very much at home.
Shortly before the
Wednesday closing time,
the uninvited guest
reappeared, more bleary of eye
than he had been
in the forenoon.
None saw him enter,
and none saw him leave.
He was later seen
on Eighth Avenue.
Under his arm was a bulky,
paper-wrapped package,
from the rear of which protruded
the legs of a particularly
fine fowl."
[LAUGHTER]
"Still later, a guard found
the bird missing from the show.
Detectives found their man
at Fourteenth and Eighth,
still looking at the world
through the medium of alcohol.
But he had an alibi.
He had a fowl, but it was a
goose that a company gave him.
The detectives thought
they caught him in the act,
but when they checked
with the company,
his story checked out."
[LAUGHTER]
"But the mysterious
goose-lover offered a deal.
Perhaps the $500,
14-pounder could
be produced at a
certain restaurant
if the exposition
manager were to offer
in exchange a dressed
turkey of something choice.
Ultimately, the
detectives arrested him
and solved the case, but they
learned a valuable lesson
for the next time.
A turkey hen does not squawk
when it is unceremoniously
bundled up and carted away.
Only gobblers squawk."
So this is all well and
good, but what about this?
The terminal, the reason
they built this whole thing
in the first place,
the plan to save
New York-- how did that go?
This is a chart of the
capacity of the station.
It was built with the
capacity to handle all traffic
in its zone, all the traffic
coming from Manhattan.
The gray area would represent
that amount of traffic.
This is how much the
railroads used it.
There was a blackout
period in World War II,
out of security concerns.
That's why there's a blank
period in the '40s there.
But you can see, it
wasn't heavily used.
Now, freight in New York
didn't go down, particularly.
It's not like the
city wasn't operating.
It was operating somewhere,
but it wasn't happening here.
There was a Railway
Express Agency.
This was a conglomerate
owned by the railroads.
It was basically UPS before
UPS existed, UPS on railroads.
If you wanted to
deliver a package,
you could do it via
Railway Express.
And they did use the
facilities as a sublease.
And as you can see, they
used it a fair amount.
So they gave the
building more utilization
than it otherwise
would have had,
but even that was
going down by the end.
There was only one
period it was anywhere
near close to real
good usage, and that
wasn't the point of what
this was being built for,
what this was supposed to do.
So what's going on here?
Well, the fact of the
matter is the railroads
were never interested
in this plan.
Maybe the Port Authority
should have taken pause
when, even in 1927, they noted
one railroad was "convinced
that the estimates of
these inland stations
would not produce the benefits
claimed, either for the public
or for the railroads."
That's not a
glowing endorsement.
The fact of the matter
is the railroads,
they didn't compete on price,
efficiency of the port.
They don't really care
about these things.
The ICC, they set prices.
It cost however much it cost.
It didn't matter what
railroad was being used.
What they valued where
their proprietary networks.
They valued they had a
line going to one area
that no one else had.
They had a special terminal
in an area of the city
that no one else
had in that area.
They provided a quality of
service that no one else had.
It was exactly their
differences that they
thought were their
competitive advantages,
and that's exactly
what this plan was
trying to do to break down.
So this was a relationship that
was really never meant to last.
They didn't want
unions, or unification,
or anything like that.
At the beginning,
the Port Authority
tried to take a
cooperative stance,
tried to work with the
railroads cooperatively
to make this stuff work.
When that was
clearly not working,
they tried to force the
railroads to use this.
The railroads responded
by issuing a tariff
on the terminal for
certain kinds of freight,
basically boycotting it.
The Port Authority
responded by lobbying
a newly-appointed federal
commissioner under FDR
to try to get the federal
government to force
use of these union terminals.
The railroads responded by
abolishing the commissioner's
role.
They fought like this
through the '30s and '40s,
but clearly, this
relationship was souring.
It was a real problem.
However, there was an even
far more severe problem
that was happening, which made
all of this near meaningless,
and that was this.
This was the next
transportation revolution.
The age of the motor truck.
Roads.
It offered a level of
flexibility and convenience
that the railroads just
could not begin to match.
And this was the death knell
for the railroad industry.
At the time that the
building was being planned,
everything moved by railroads.
By the 1940s, about
2/3 of freight
was now moving via
long-distance trucks.
These original 12 railroads
that were serving the city?
In 1958, they were down to five.
1960, four.
1970, two.
The railroads were dying.
This was a huge problem.
This building, the
Comprehensive Plan,
the existence of the
Port Authority itself--
it was all built for an era
that was completely collapsing
around them.
This whole
Comprehensive Plan thing
was now becoming increasingly,
alarmingly irrelevant.
That's not good.
The Port Authority responded to
this by basically jumping ship.
They abandoned their
original purpose
and dove into this new
world of the automobile,
without ever really
looking back.
They saw that these trucks,
this whole truck industry,
had the same exact problems
as the railroad industry,
of duplication, and
so on and so on.
And they end up identifying
the same pattern,
and they end up proposing the
same exact solution for trucks.
So in the 1940s, they
proposed a new station,
Inland Terminal Number Two.
It would be 1,000 feet long by
175 feet, a union motor truck
terminal, doing the same
exact thing as this one.
It would be the
biggest in the world.
It opened in November of 1949,
at the corner of Washington
Street and Houston Street.
And it had the
same exact results.
No one used it.
The trucking
companies, they didn't
want to lose their
individual identity.
So it limped along below
capacity for a number of years,
until UPS signed on
as an anchor tenant.
And they eventually bought
the building in 1992.
This is what it
looks like today.
But you know, the Port Authority
is committed or stubborn,
depending on your
vantage point, and they
said, let's do it again.
Let's try it again.
[LAUGHTER]
So in 1945, they proposed
an even bigger terminal.
[LAUGHTER]
Union Motor Truck
Terminal Number Three,
1,100 feet by 200 feet,
and definitely the largest
in the world.
They made another
pretty rendering for it.
And this one opened in 1951.
This was an immediate disaster.
[LAUGHTER]
The local trucking
unions boycotted it.
They didn't want to use it.
And this one limped
badly for a while.
And then this, too,
ultimately got sold in 1980.
This is what it
looks like today.
But how about this one,
Inland Terminal Number One,
the original one, the one that
started all of this happening?
What happened with them,
with it, with here?
This is going to sound sad.
It continued its slow
decline into sad irrelevance
over the years.
In 1957, the first serious
downsizing happened.
That's when the railroads,
for the first time,
subleased a big
chunk of the terminal
and ceased to
exclusively use it.
By 1963, the railroads
officially ended their leases
and stopped using it.
Railway Express
continued on for a while,
but they also fell
onto hard times,
and they fell
apart in the 1960s.
The Port Authority,
meanwhile, they
were interested in other things.
They were paying
a lot of attention
to managing the region's
airports, to creating
new shipping
terminals, especially
in Elizabeth and Newark,
to the PATH stations,
and to their newest pet
project, the World Trade Center.
The World Trade Center
opened up in April of 1973.
Same time, the Port Authority
put this building up
for sale at auction.
They ultimately sold it to
that real estate developer
known as Sylvan
Lawrence, which used
to be a very big developer
in New York, for $24 million.
Port Authority themselves,
they moved their headquarters
then from the 15th
floor of this building
into the new World Trade Center.
And the long and
the storied identity
of this building as
more than something
than just another New
York office building
was officially over.
Which begs the question, was
this union terminal theory
just misfounded?
I'm going to really
quickly summarize
between 1973 and today.
Sylvan Lawrence
bought the company,
as I mentioned earlier.
They added some
significant tenants
like the St. Vincent's Cancer
Center, and BarnesandNoble.com
in the '90s.
But in the '80s and
'90s, they themselves
started to fall apart
as an organization.
One of the partners
died, and there
became this horrible
legal dispute
between his widow and
the other partner,
and basically, the
whole company dissolved.
In 1998, I think it was,
they sold their last four
properties in Manhattan.
They used to have
128 properties.
They sold their
last four properties
to a partnership of
Blackacre Capital and Taconic
Investments, for a
deal of $387.5 million
across the four properties.
Then Taconic bought
it out, and they
continued to seriously
update the building.
They created the
efforts of turning this
into the carrier hotel that made
it basically a holder of some
of the backbone infrastructure
of the internet.
And they started to
attract a lot more
upscale, quote-unquote,
"first class" tenants.
They attracted one particularly
ambitious and hungry tenant
called Google, if I'm
pronouncing that right--
[LAUGHTER]
--who moved here in 2006
onto the fourth floor.
Google eventually bought the
building outright in 2010,
for $1.9 billion
dollars, which is easily
one of the largest real
estate deals in US history.
So what became of all the
main characters of this story?
The trucking industry continued
to rise without challenge,
and became what today is the
unambiguously dominant form
of transport across the land.
Today, about 65% of US
freight moves via truck.
In New York, it's 90%.
We see this directly in the
congestion and pollution
that we see on our
city streets every day.
The railroads?
By the time this building
was sold in 1973,
the industry was already
solidly collapsing.
The last old railroad empires,
they bankrupted in the 1970s,
and they were ultimately folded
into a government agency called
Conrail.
But the concept never died.
Railroads still exist.
They're still good
at what they do.
And even today, about 11% of
US freight moves via rail,
and it's still a $60
billion dollar industry.
As for the Port
of New York, it's
still a major port,
an important port,
but it's no longer the biggest.
It's now third behind Los
Angeles and Long Beach.
Critically, all of the
port infrastructure
migrated from Manhattan over
to Elizabeth and Newark.
You can kind of see that if
you look at the container
ships and those facilities when
you're by Newark Airport today.
And that's why we have parks on
the Manhattan waterfront today
instead of shipping piers.
Oh, and that tunnel that was
part of the Comprehensive Plan
that would connect Jersey
City to Bay Ridge in Brooklyn,
there's a lot of talk of trying
to rebuild that again today.
So maybe there was
really something to that.
That 90% of freight that comes
by truck, maybe that whole rail
thing still matters.
The Port Authority?
They're as big and relevant and
involved with as many things
as ever, as anyone who has
used any of the airports,
used any of the tunnels-- the
Lincoln Tunnel or the Holland
Tunnel-- the George Washington
Bridge, rides a PATH train,
stairs up at the new
World Trade Center,
or has heard of
"Bridge-gate," knows about.
Oh, and that terminal concept,
that unified terminal concept,
that one that they
tried three times
and failed at three
times, that one which
is part of the very founding
of why the organization was
created, their plan
to save New York,
all that-- well,
they tried it again.
[LAUGHTER]
In the 1950s, they
found yet another case
where there were
disparate carriers who
had duplicated infrastructure
and weren't really
working efficiently together.
So they built another
union terminal.
And this one, this
time, it worked.
This one was wildly
successful and is still
heavily used today.
And yes, it did originally
looked like that.
Finally, of course, there's
this, 111 Eighth Avenue,
the one that started it all.
It may have failed in its--
[LAUGHTER]
It may have failed in its stated
purpose, original purpose,
but clearly something
clicked with this building
at some point.
Now a thriving home
to Google, where
we're building the
transportation pipelines that
define our own digital
era, some of this vision
of scientific progress
and efficient networks
is finally thriving, albeit
under wildly different
circumstances than its designers
ever might have imagined,
and in a form unique to this
very different, but perhaps
no less peculiar, age
in which we now live.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
If anyone wants
to ask questions,
you're more than welcome to, and
there are microphones set up.
Hey.
What is one of the
original design
elements of the building that
we, as Googlers, can still
see today?
What is your favorite one?
That's a tough one.
My personal favorite is
15th floor elevator lobby.
That's where the executive
office of the Port Authority
themselves were,
and you can still
see it clearly looks different
than all the other elevator
lobbies.
It looks nicer.
And it even has insignias
of-- there's seagulls
sculpted into the
walls, which are
part of the insignia
of the Port Authority.
It's something you
might not particularly
notice if you're
not looking for it,
but you can definitely
feel the history in that.
So what's with those
weird bumps of concrete
on the side of the
building outside?
Well, you know, it was built
as a truck terminal, which
meant the entirety of 15th
and 16th Streets from Eighth
to Ninth Avenue were
intended for merchant trucks
to come in and load
and unload freight.
So that was to protect
the building from trucks
banging into the structures.
We still have a little
bit of that, right?
There's still a few
loading bays for that.
But most of that has
been replaced by walls
and first floor tenants.
Go ahead.
Yes.
Isn't there something
to do with this building
and the Transatlantic
Cable or ISPs in general?
That's a great question, and
there very well might be.
My level of knowledge
about this building
doesn't actually
go to that point.
So when it came to
the modern history
of this building
and its connection
with the internet and
internet infrastructure,
I honestly don't know any
better than you do about that.
But I think there are
people in this room who
probably could tell you that.
So as part of one of
the advertisements,
the building had
a penthouse level.
Were there ever people
living on the 16th--
This building here?
Yes.
I did not see that.
I don't know.
It's an interesting question.
They were actually planning
14 stories for this building.
I don't know when the 15th,
and then ultimately whatever
we had with the 16th came up.
But maybe it's
something to explore.
Thank you.
So one of the things that
I'm curious about here--
you talked a lot about
all of this rail freight
coming into New Jersey, and then
having to cross into Manhattan.
Why was that?
Was stuff being
manufactured in Manhattan
that this was raw goods for?
Was it stuff that was
supplying the New York area?
Why not just put it onto
ships in New Jersey?
Well, that's also
what happened, right?
Today, the Port of New York,
including the waterfront part
of it, does happen
in New Jersey.
But it's basically the
history of-- New York
became a big and important city
well before New Jersey did.
So New Jersey still
is, but at the time,
it was many smaller
municipalities which
couldn't really cooperate
with each other,
so they really couldn't
provide a good infrastructure
for ports.
So the big city,
which was originally
Manhattan, and
eventually New York,
they had their act
together, and that just
became the natural focal point.
And of course, the Erie
Canal, when that developed,
things like New Jersey
didn't matter so much.
So it's basically historical.
But ultimately, what
you're saying absolutely
does make a difference, and that
is how things ultimately went.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]